Well, let's have a look at how to do this. Again, we're giving an arbitrary
point on the flag. Let's remember that x moves this way, y moves this way. So,
in this case the y value doesn't matter at all. What matters is where x is. The
total width here is given to us, so this cutoff here is width over 3 and this
one is width times 2 over 3. So, the first condition here is going to be x less
than width over 3 or maybe less than equal width over 3. Let's settle that. So,
let's assume that the width was 300, then x could be any value between 0 and
299. The first 100 values, from 0 to 99 should be blue. The values from 100 to
199 should be white. And the values from 200 to 299 should be red. So, the last
value that stays in this branch here should be x equals 99. With the 300, width
over 3 is 100. So the less than is correct. We want to be less than 100 to stay
here. As soon as we're between 100 and less than 2 3rds of the width, we want
to be in the middle brand, branch. And, finally, if neither of those is true,
then we want to be here. And thats the code. The takeaway is, if you need to
make multiple decisions, then you use the if, else if, else clause. Sarah has
prepared a bunch of practice problems for you, so that you get more exercises
that involve making these kinds of decisions. Have fun.